Halloween is such a fun holiday.
Here's a unique "At Home" idea to help wow your guest and your trick-or-treaters.
Today I'm gonna show you how to transform your entryway table into a candy bar.
You can choose a table runner.
Here I've got some really cool gauze.
It's an easy way to add tone and texture...
...and then this serves as your foundation so you can start layering your display.
Next, add some height for that visual punch.
These glass jars do just the trick...
...and the treat when you fill them with colorful candy just for show.
Now, a really easy design tip for adding depth is to vary the heights of your jars.
You can do that by stacking them on books or boxes.
Fill in any empty spaces you see with small decorative items.
You can throw in some spooky spiders, creepy cobwebs or some scary skeletons.
And then for ambience, I've just added these votive candles.
These are actually very realistic-looking LED lights.